all right hey what's going on it's bill
bird it's time for
a thursday afternoon just before friday
monday morning podcast
and usually i'm just checking in on you
to see how your uh
your work week's going and that type of
stuff you know to run my yap and every
once in a while i have a special guest
um and this podcast is uh one of those
special guest ones i have
from a guy i started out with well i
learned from
when i started in boston um
he has gone on to tour the entire
friggin world
he's been in like every fairly brother
movie said
something about mary and now he's landed
a series regular role on is it on amazon
amazon prime amazon prime hit uh
loudermilk starring ron livingston will
sasso brian regan is in it
and the one and only boston comedy
legend
jackie flynn everybody ever give me a
big head bill
i am no i'm giving you a nice you got a
beautiful hollywood head
i always felt you know you got the jaw
you had the hate
you had everything like actually this
side by side you got on one side what
hollywood was looking for
and then you got me yeah i'm more of the
uh i'm what's known as a
uh character actor good looks
that's the way it's saying you're a
weird [ __ ] but we'll find a place for
you
we'll fix you um dude i got to tell you
i watched the pilot
of louder milk ron livingston who i
worked with a long long long long time
ago
a lot of hair ago for me uh i love
seeing him being the lead in anything
i always watch his stuff so it was great
to see him
and uh i watched the pilot it's
basically about a guy
uh i don't know how would you a
curmudgeony guy who yeah
he kind of you know his first wife died
i don't want to give away too much in a
very tragic way
that burdens him right yeah
you're close but there's a little bit of
twist and stuff in there but yeah that's
that's
basically it okay all right i only saw
the first one yeah i know
that really a lot of stuff afterwards
but yeah
and how many episodes did you guys do we
did uh
three seasons of 10 each so 30 episodes
and the hope is is that
it does well in amazon prime and then
they decide to you know make more
seasons because peter furley
produced and uh you know directed with
bobby mort
uh they envisioned this being you know
eight nine episodes excuse me uh eight
nine seasons long so
we're hoping we get the chance because
we got so much stuff to delve into it's
just starting
it's just getting going really and we've
had a blast and it's getting it builds
every every season
you're already three seasons and how do
you keep up with what the hell hell's
going on how the fella
you've been a series regular on
something for three seasons and you
haven't rubbed that in my face
well you know i i i you know i still
wouldn't i still wouldn't be able to
come close to your
uh what you've been doing but let me
tell you bill we shot it up in canada
and it was on the directv's audience
channel and nobody saw it you know
forever
and then directv uh kind of merged with
hbo or bought hbo and then now the hbo
max is there
so they made our channel the audience
channel on directv a preview channel for
hbo max and so we had no home
and then they've been shopping it you
know hopefully trying to find a home for
it and finally
you finally found a home yes thank god
good deal good deal well i'm yeah i'm
excited well now i'm going to try to
watch the whole thing it's called
louder milk which i was like what does
that mean
like yeah is did you spike the milk is
the milk gone bad it's just the guy's
last name
yes louder milk sam loudermilk
you know loudermilk you know i worked in
a movie one time and the head bad guy's
last name was clap hands
clap hands his first name was mister his
i had to be like hey i'm [ __ ] working
for mr claphaunts
yeah don't touch him stay away from mr
claphams
it was a fun movie though it actually
you know it's a good movie too but like
that i like when they actually come up
with some sort of
you know offbeat name yeah i like that
it's
called louder milk because you go louder
mouth what the [ __ ] does that mean and
then you click on it
you know it's funny too this guy there's
actually a congressman from like i want
to say north carolina or something
that's
congressman loudermilk if you if you
google it you'll see it comes up like
with
underneath like that's i never heard
that the name loudermilk i i actually
didn't know it was the last name
how did peter come up with that name no
idea
i don't know i i don't know if he even
did i think it might have been bobby
moore i want to say for some reason but
i'm not sure they created at the show
together and then uh
you know we all right me and jimmy dunn
actually wrote uh with pete a couple
episodes
uh together uh in season two and three
dude you're all over this thing i love
it and you got you're playing uh you're
on here to promote that you're gonna be
at uh
crackers in indianapolis uh this weekend
right
friday and saturday two shows one at
eight each night just two shows one
friday one saturday
so what's that may 28th may 29th yes i'm
going i'm out there for the indy 500.
my uh yeah i told you my daughter's
boyfriend's an indycar driver which is
they're the craziest thing in my life
just wait is he driving in that race
driving he's in second place he almost
won the pole position by a
300th of a second he lost it to uh scott
dixon because he had some tape slapping
on his car and it slowed him down
he should have taken the pole holy [ __ ]
it's crazy i went over to jackie's house
people watching this thing i went over
the other day uh
we watched a bruins game before the
playoffs started
smoked some cigars and all that type of
stuff and uh i met him briefly
um i didn't know he was racing at that
level
i just yeah i don't know enough about
racing i just i was like all right
just i didn't either and now i'm like
all in i mean i'm going to
you know i've been like i'm watching i
know what kind of
whatever it means qualifying you know
you know the laps
pit stops and there's a lot more that
goes into it then you have no idea you
know growing up in boston i you know i
was a
boston you know fan of all you know just
baseball basketball football hockey
and racing would be there and you kind
of go okay you know whatever i just
never really knew what it was
and now all of a sudden i'm uh i'm
afraid have you ever been to a uh indy
yes a couple of years ago i went the
first time to see colton and we're all
excited
and colton's car [ __ ] to bed and he it
was five laps
he only lasted five laps out of 500. and
uh
so now we're hoping god willing he'll be
better you know but it's also terrifying
the more i know the kids i love him
it's terrifying watching yeah did you
notice
um what's hilarious when i went to the
indy 500 long time ago
mid 90s yeah what was funny was
the level of intelligence in the pits
yeah and then right across the track
when you went to the stand
all of us animals yeah you know that
welcome race fans and back then you
could bring your own cooler in and just
get [ __ ]
up list yeah so there's just like
that you know there's not saying there's
not some drunk gearheads in there but
for the most part
it was a bunch of animals like me
you know you you just bet every car like
whatever there's 40 cars you got five
cars you got five cars i got five
everybody's like put money and you bet
it like 50 different ways just getting
absolutely shit-faced yeah and they're
literally sitting there
if one piece of whatever is out of
alignment they go from
first place to second place or maybe
back to fourth place
so um i always got kind of like you
don't see that in f1
f1 has a really snobby
sort of rich richie you know [ __ ]
richard naughty like crowd but like the
indie
500 yeah man i love it
it's great i'm telling you i'm really
into it way more than i thought i'd be
and i you know of course i got a dog in
the fight you know so
you know i was on [ __ ] michael vick
here but no i got a dog in the fight you
know and i i give a [ __ ] you know
well tell me about uh i started in
boston in 1992
and you were just one of the guys that
you're just like this guy's [ __ ]
funny
this was back when you know we were all
trying to get on like star search and
yeah comedy on the road and all of that
[ __ ]
and i can remember okay i'm sorry do you
remember that showcase
when uh ed mcmahon
came to the comedy connection in in
boston and it was like
the deal was like he was he was going
out on the road this season
to to to see the talent in person
and what i think what was really
happening was the ratings were slipping
yeah so he had to go out he had to go
out and go do a tour and i remember he
was there with this
chick he was over in the corner so i
never did the tonight show with
johnny carson but i performed in front
of ed mcmahon he sat way up stage left
you know over
the corner sure yeah we all went up
trying to like
took all our dick jokes out we all tried
to be like squeaky clean
well i didn't i didn't do that because i
had already prior to that a couple years
earlier lost on star search so
that's how long i was it was like i
think i went on it like 90 i think i did
star search
and i i lost uh a terrifying experience
yeah what was that like did they shoot
that during the day was it at night
it was uh yeah like the late afternoon
it was down in florida we shot it they
used to shoot it in hollywood i think
then they shot it in florida
like treasure island down there you know
like a universal area there and uh
it was just crazy and i i lost a another
thing i lost to cassie chappelle
who's a comic i don't know if you ever
heard of cassie chappelle and she
literally had like a big like wig thing
on and she like almost like pulled her
head off at the end of the show like
that was her big
thing like it was just the craziest
thing and uh
i thought you have to go on after it no
i i did
uh i think i went up i got i got three
point
four star i i get four stars i got three
point nine star whatever i got
i got like as much as you can get
without getting four stars and she got
four stars and beat me
and i was like i wanted an investigation
it was like
were you in the money round at that
point no i was just starting out you
know i was just trying to you know
whatever but i mean i did as good as i
could do you get two minutes you know
i feel like a freaking egg you know it's
just ridiculous
well as people will notice dude you're
the rapid fire guy so like
in those two minutes what did you do 40
50 jokes
i probably did besides i don't think
there's anyone faster besides gavin
maybe
you know i mean gavin you know makes me
look slow
uh but i can remember billy when you
said you came around i remember 92 i can
remember
like clear as day you hanging out with
hanging out in the green room and the
finial hall comedy connection
you know with frank you know when frank
used to run it and frank hearn there and
uh god bless him and uh
i i remember you just this big you
shocked her i just said this kid but
you had like you were so happy yeah if
people knew you then like they
i always have trouble you know uh
reconciling the you of now with that
because you're just so
to me i always have that and a few of
you in my in my
brain and then i see oh yeah i was
little billy burr i was a
uh i was just a kid and i
uh it probably took another six years
yup before i developed fully into an
angry young man
[Laughter]
you know it all takes the strength which
by the way dude what the hell are you
doing you know
i know but i got to tell you i i in this
this year i've been going to therapy and
i just
unburdened myself of all of that [ __ ]
that made me angry and now i'm in this
weird i'm in this weird place dude where
like
uh not being angry like it feels good
but it doesn't feel like home
yeah like i don't know i don't know what
to do with all this space in my chest
now and
i'm sitting there like i know what
happened to you too you had you had kids
and kids uh you know you start to you
know think differently you know that
whole thing it's a whole different
life-changing event i think and uh
but you know because you you think like
i can't
i can't pass this on again no
this has to break the cycle
this has to die with me what did um
yeah like i i mean that's why i quit
drinking yeah dude i was like getting
[ __ ]
like blitzed my daughter would be
upstairs
and i'm like oh my god i'm going to be
the dad who drinks
and they were like nights dude not maybe
nights there was months
in a row where almost every night i
would sit down and i would watch me tv
i'd watch like a bunch of adam 12s or
something and i would just get
[ __ ] like drink three big ones and
just get [ __ ] hammered and i and
there was always that guilt going like
god forbid something happened and you
had to take her to the hospital right
now you couldn't do it
so it makes sense no pun intended
you know and it really is it makes you
uh it makes you rethink a lot of stuff
and
what's important and you know comedians
i mean [ __ ] i used to say that too it's
a monday night and i'm at a club
you know tuesday night's safe calling
and i'm drinking six beers and i'm like
you know
you know now that's like you should have
six beers a week you know and i'm like a
tuesday going what the [ __ ] you know
like and i'm not i really never found i
don't feel like i'm an alcohol you know
i definitely you know drink more than
the average bird but i'm saying i'm
saying they're going cheese
you know i'm drinking six beers on a
tuesday night you know two beers before
going on stage one on stage someone
sends you a [ __ ] shot
you know god forbid the three show
saturday nights i remember like
every comic has one show that you just
kind of were repeating jokes and [ __ ]
you know
man i'll never do that again you know
weren't you you were a beer on stage guy
i think
i think you used to go up what was your
drink was it a butt or a bud light
i usually have bud light and then i went
to uh mick ultra you know always trying
to watch my girlish figure
you know and still get drunk
[Laughter]
so when you go back and watch your tapes
you guess what you're not by the outfit
but by what beer you're drinking
what beer i'm drinking yeah yeah corona
that was about
about 94 rolling rockets would really
date you i would think
yeah i i just uh you know i i just
remember i remember one year
the owner of the comedy connection
started charging us for beers i remember
i was so [ __ ] outraged
and i uh i made my little little protest
you know i
said like you got to make money on your
headliner i mean really you know i mean
so i ended up uh bringing my own bud
light into the green room i left the bud
light cans all because i didn't sell
cans obviously so i just made my little
protestation you know
well i mean to be fair to the club owner
yeah i mean yeah guys noxie
yeah guys as hard as they kill could
drink just as hard like uh
kevin knox gavin could put him away
uh rest his soul dog man i remember when
nazi like right after he would finish a
triathlete
with this guy kevin knox right boston
comedy legend for people
not familiar with them had this big
lion's mane alike hair right
this mullet oh you wear a tennis outfit
yeah and he always came in like a track
suit and just and it wasn't like you
know like a hipster thing like he he was
he was the guy hipsters dressed like
like the royal tenon bombs
were dressing like him how he really
dressed and he would come up there
and just absolutely [ __ ] murder
and then and he would party afterwards
but then he always was
getting ready for a triathlon and when
he would get ready for a triathlon he
would be totally [ __ ] clean and sober
but then the second he finished the
thing he would immediately pick up which
i can't imagine how
about the strain on your heart doing
that and i saw him one night down at the
um
the comedy connection he was so
shit-faced he couldn't remember his
jokes
and i remember you do some quick little
joke between comics because he would
always host the show
and he was making fun of that beer
commercial like uh
like hey i'll uh i'll race you to the
bottom for a michelob light remember
that ski commercial
yeah yeah yeah and he was just like [ __ ]
you i'll buy one you know it was just a
stupid
joke and he went like that he was so
shit-faced he just goes
i shouldn't wanna make a little light he
just goes
huh made like this noise and gave the
crowd the finger they're like look at
that i'm like what the [ __ ]
you just get it out no and then he was
like going for the laugh dude he looked
like he was on
everything and that was like i actually
loved that set because
i felt like all of that [ __ ] happened
all the time
like right i showed up right as the
party ended i showed up in 92
the 80s boom was over every comic was
opening with
like you know so i've been sober for
three months it's over
[ __ ] a year everybody like the whole
[ __ ] thing
that's happened a lot in my career by
the way you know he
he uh he used to always do that uh he
used to have those woo-woos remember
those shots the
red uh like vodka and cranberry is
called a woo
everybody would be lined up and you'd
have all all those [ __ ] minions
you know you'd be giving everybody their
shots like uh
like jim jones and [ __ ] you know
guyana
i was afraid to drink with i i actually
didn't
there was a period where i didn't drink
because
i saw how it affected all of those
people's careers
it wasn't really that it was more the
blow and all those guys that
had like uh you know the irs was
garnishing their wages and they couldn't
leave the state i'm telling you there's
a [ __ ] show in there somewhere
absolutely uh yeah but then i showed up
and i started out with
with dane patrice and bobby kelly and
they were all
like dane never drank bobby was sober
and patrice just wasn't into
drinking so i hung with them thank god
because dude i would have been i would
have been
a yeah you would have been i would tell
him with you lunatics
i tell you i always for somehow i always
just
i don't know why i just i always had
that shut off switch thank god
you know obviously a couple times no but
for the most part in my my life i always
just
i don't know i just couldn't do it i
didn't have that i didn't have an
addictive personality
i mean people can hang around with me
for a whole weekend and then never give
me another [ __ ] thought
goodnight everybody no but i seriously i
never had that [ __ ] type of uh
you know addictive you know type thing
but um
i do remember patrice i remember patrice
[ __ ] he was a doorman
when i was headlining i used to come in
and he'd be like jackie
and he was the [ __ ] most fun and you
know never even dreaming that he'd be
peace eventually someday you know what i
mean all of a sudden he started doing
open mind i remember seeing him go
[ __ ] patrice
all right you know and all of a sudden
uh you know again god bless them but
jesus that was just
surreal to me you know yeah no i'm i'm
kind of thankful that uh
that that whole time exists you know
what was great back then too was
like i mean george carlin had an opener
but other than that
first of all everyone was working clubs
yeah so you couldn't really afford to
bring a guy on the road with you
no so we all got to work with open for
all of these huge acts they'd come
downtown and
remember like the club would call you up
i remember i got to i got to do a
weekend with david alan greer
remember that that chicopee run or
whatever the hell it was that uh
yeah yeah the chinese joint yes
yeah yeah yeah yeah everything i mean
like comedy and chinese places
in boston
the hong kongs yeah like it just they
they
asian people like are as as responsible
for the boston comedy scene
as the comedians because they were all
about it they were like yeah get your
friends in here we're getting poo poo
platters
yeah all that [ __ ] joke that's what they
call them back there
and you know what bill yeah the aku in
cambridge
i grew up in arlington we used to go
there at night you know adopted
drinking at a place called faces right
on route 2 there we'd go to aku
for like prom night and stuff and then
years later i'm doing stand-up in there
it was the most surreal thing in the
world you know dick i think dick dardy
was booking it right
i always try to find that place like
what like what is that today they
probably just called the summer shot now
it's summer shack it's like a
a a boston like uh fish joint like kind
of
the class still the same structure uh i
think they changed it it's been a long
time since i've been by there too
but it's right there you know as you go
over fresh pond bridge right there you
know
yeah because i remember that was like
yeah dame was from arlington too so that
was right around the corner from his
house
yeah um dame dan overtook me i was the
arlington guy and then all of a sudden
dane came in i'm like what the [ __ ] how
many guys could be from arlington they
got al de leni they got michael pryor
i'm like what the [ __ ] i started a
[ __ ] just you know it's hysterical to
me
who did you uh when i came up i
opened for david out everyone from dave
and allen grier to like wendy leedman
yeah um i used to do gigs with wendy we
used to do gigs all the time with road
gigs like barry cats would send us in
these
hellholes but you know who i did open
for that i was most excited i'm still
waiting for the money
yeah yeah yeah right
so i think billy down still owes me a
couple hundred bucks
but anyway i'm walking uh i was working
for me my dad was a big fan and i ended
up getting
like the tonight show and stuff but i
got to open for steve allen which is
crazy i mean
i mean talk about a renaissance guy my
dad used to say steve allen my dad had
the greatest sense of humor anyone i
knew
and he would just howl my dad would have
tears in his eyes you know steve allen
on whatever but you know when he used to
run the tonight show way before i was
even born
but then i got my other dad's favorite
uh comedian was pat cooper and i get to
open for pat cooper
life is always so bittersweet you know
the only guy you want to impress is your
old man of course my dad's dead and i'm
opening for pat cooper i'm eating in
federal hill and rhode island you know
providence eating
italian dinner with them and then you
know driving to the club and he's
telling me shows stories it's just
incredible just incredible matt cooper
is arguably the most underrated comedian
as far as like
unbelievable how funny he is how long
he's been that funny
yes and how much energy had i opened for
a bill i was like in my 30s maybe
and he was 60 something and i'm telling
you he had more energy than me i never
seen anything like it and non-stop for
an hour
on stage just killing it yeah i will
tell you
uh unresolved anger is like rocket fuel
[ __ ] which is what i'm worried about
i'm gonna end up being like a [ __ ]
yoga instructor but
you know i unfortunately for pat he
should have been a big big star and
and i also commend him for this because
he spoke his mind he never took any [ __ ]
and he
and unfortunately to his demise you know
it it it hurt him but
he told me i looked at him like he
thought it was the white version of
patrice
where it was like with i mean i don't
know i could shouldn't speak for pat
cooper like that but like i remember
patrice was one of these people where it
was just like if you just didn't say
that last thing
it was there you had it
everybody's got to make a little bit of
a compromise yeah each play that you
know
yeah he couldn't do it he couldn't do it
such a [ __ ] sometimes and i wish i
could say some stuff or do say some
stuff you know
dude you know how many times i thought
that you know many times to this day
sometimes i just do [ __ ] just accept it
and i just think like oh god i just wish
i had that
patrice thing yeah i do we all do
it's almost like the same way when
you're driving down the road and some
guy does something and you start
thinking about what you [ __ ]
should have done today you know i should
have stopped and pulled that guy out of
his car
you know yeah [ __ ] that you should have
done you know and it aggravates you for
the next it's better it's better not to
do it because
there's no no upside down
yeah you know that whole that sinatra
song i remember patrice used to play
that thing
i did it my way yeah yeah and not the
words of one who kneels and he'd be
singing this [ __ ] going like
dude this is like great advice if you
know how to apply it
yeah yeah it's like all those
contradicting sayings so
um let me ask you this during like this
whole pandemic you know you got the um
you got this this weekend coming up at
crackers in um indianapolis
how have you been working out your stuff
you know
i don't know this will be my third or
fourth time on stage since the pandemic
started
i was uh i went from march i came home
march 16th
i was doing a i was supposed to do a
saint patty's day gig down in uh
in naples florida and they canceled it
and then so i flew home the 16th of
march and then
i didn't do anything in november i had a
gig down in florida
a corporate gig and i needed you know
too much money and i couldn't say i
needed to do it you know i hadn't worked
in freaking nine months
so i go and do the gig in florida at
this like private golf club type thing
was outdoors in a tent but still
like nerium asking site you know and it
was like i actually almost opened with
you know nice to be here i never played
at trump rally before
but i figured that would lose half the
crowd all the crowd so i instead
i opted for the less offensive nice to
be here at camp covent
so so i do that and then i uh
i do all right and i but i it was great
i tell you let go i always go too fast
so this made me go slow because i was
literally trying to remember my [ __ ] so
it was actually
kind of good and it also gave me a new
found love for comedy again because
i wasn't just phoning it in you know
sometimes you get into the
routine you know oh yeah no that's
that's the kiss of death let me ask you
what is the um
why do you think you your your your
style like going that
fast where like you ever just like look
at like when i look at early tapes of me
yeah i'm going really fast and i am
pacing the stage and
boss for me it was i realized it was uh
it was a confidence it was nervous
energy but like you've been doing this
yeah for [ __ ] ever and your smoothest
silk
on stage ever since i've known you and
are you one of those guys where when you
lay down at night like your brain is
torturing you with thoughts
is it just so much not so much i do have
a lot of thoughts and uh i wish i was a
better
editor like you know i have a lot of
thoughts i think about stuff
no you might i mean like let's put this
away first of all
i think it was a boston thing because
god forbid i used to call it like you
have to kill the silence god forbid
there's any silence
you know you have to like you can't you
know you have to get there can't be
silenced they have to be laughing at all
time or are you talking
you know nothing can never be [ __ ] a
pause and i learned from gavin and you
know although
guys other guys i learned from didn't do
that like kenny rogerson you know was
another mentor of mine you know but
but anyway my personality just fit more
like with gavin's and i was always and i
think it was a nervous thing you didn't
want to have any [ __ ] silence or a
confidence thing you know you had to
make sure god forbid there there's a
pause you know what i mean so
but to answer your other question at
night you know i do have like
you know jokes and stuff but i don't
have uh i don't get it well my my
biggest problem is
that i would if i could edit better i i
could i could be a lot more effective i
think too
what when you what was your childhood
like did you have a big family
did you have my words in me and my two
sisters i was the oldest and i had two
sisters that
are you know younger one eleven months
younger and one uh like six years
younger
than uh but my dad was a maniac my dad
like you know my dad
i love my dad but he was like you know i
was always walking around on pins and
needles you know if my dad was in a good
mood everything was good but god forbid
he was in a bad mood you know
i was always walking around on eggshells
you know that was
everybody's dad yeah my dad's a maniac i
love the guy he's a [ __ ]
maniac well i come over bill i looked at
a big street at big hill
and literally when report cards came i
can remember like being a nervous wreck
and i'd come over the hill and if this
car was in the [ __ ] driveway i'd have
a [ __ ] pit in my stomach
oh you know because he'd make a big
dramatic thing about it you know like
one time you know just
i'm sure he was winking at my mom
afterwards you know but he'd take my
credit
uh my report card and throw it and you
know and you know the [ __ ] you know and
i'd be like
sitting there [ __ ] you know terrified
and i mean you know and i don't want to
paint the wrong picture because my dad
he had the greatest heart great guy but
he you know if he could do it i'm sure
he would do something differently
i know but they didn't have the tools
the information wasn't out there dude no
you weren't living you lived in the
bubble of your neighborhood you were as
smart as the people on your street there
wasn't this
this like now where you know like the
the [ __ ] access people have with the
internet
you know it's a good and a bad thing but
like you know i always equate it to like
learning an
instrument yeah like back in the day you
had to like slow the wreck down figure
it out but now you can go on [ __ ]
youtube
and you could literally have the guy who
played it show you how to play it and
just
it's like your teacher is the whole
[ __ ] universe
well we just grew up on like wherever
you grew up
dude you could be there's like a
different kind of ignorance in each town
because it was you were all just in
living in these pods
feeding off of each other i remember
bill i remember one night i was telling
my buddy this
my dad and his buddies were drinking you
know and they're outside
you remember the bats like you know in
boston you know and hourly to the
suburbs
we looked in the woods kind of a little
bit there's bats my dad with his buddies
had a 12-gauge shotgun they were [ __ ]
shooting the bats out of the sky
in the middle of the [ __ ] night in
the neighborhood like 10 at night i mean
where the [ __ ] would that ever fly you
know
just like you know there's so much stuff
if there was uh
if there was video and all of that stuff
you would definitely be
uh you'd definitely be in trouble but um
anyway let's talk let's talk a little
boston sports dude like what um
what would it have two boston guys what
a massachusetts guys what would it be
like if we didn't talk sports here so
we got to have and a half knots with the
bruins and the celtics the celtics are
just
up against yeah how much whatever the
nba is now where everybody just sort of
you know jumps on two or three different
teams we're not one of the teams
everybody's jumping on right now so
we're getting our [ __ ] asses handed
to us
well i tell you what i've been i'm not
as it's funny
basketball i don't follow it like i used
to i in the celtics get in the playoffs
i watch
and stuff but i'm not a big big
basketball guy anymore i used to with
larry bird and uh
magic those that era i loved it you know
i was younger and more into it i guess
but um you didn't watch right through
jordan i thought it was great
right through jordan and watching those
spurs teams but i felt like
the kobe shack lakers was sort of
foreshadowing
what was going to happen where it it
became um
i mean it seems to be like it's really
good for their business model
because it's not like it only works in
la like a bunch of people i think
watched when golden state
you know when kevin durant was on there
and like sure so i think people
uh i feel like they create like mini
dream teams now
and they just sort of play each other
and you're gonna like
it's just gonna hope that your team's
one of those teams that does it i guess
i don't know
i i guess for me too it's always been
what bothered me first of all i got
really annoyed with the whole refs
the the cheating scandal i was i was
betting on sacramento in that [ __ ]
game and i
i called it i said i said this is a
[ __ ] bag job i'll never forget it
i saw the whole thing like kobe like
literally trampled vlady
at the foul line and like ran over and
they get the ball and they called the
follow on black
on vlady and i'm like are you kidding it
was the most and sure enough that's the
[ __ ] game they were talking about
being
in the background i i went to a celtics
utah jazz game
yeah and i watched that officiating
proof because they put it on that
donahee guy they put on like one guy
yeah yeah like first of all if you and i
were on an officiating crew
and i'm shaving points how many games
are you officiating with me before you
figure it out
yeah exactly like what the [ __ ] is bill
doing over there right and i was
watching
the utah jazz play the boston celtics in
utah
and i watched them like change
how they were calling the game like four
times during that game
where it's like oh they're letting them
play tonight
oh no wait now they're calling
everything now they're letting them play
again it was like they were switching
out official because
it was like there was always the tone
was set and i would and i remember going
down the cellar just saying
these the [ __ ] nba is fixed and yeah
didn't help but i was also talking about
the bilderberg group and the [ __ ] you
know the
federal reserve so they just thought i
was a nut job
so when that ref finally got busted i
was so like felt so vindicated
yeah and i was like you see and then
they did the oswald thing oh he acted
alone it was just him
well i'll tell you in that same game
chris webber just comes driving down the
lane
to for a layup and the guy gets tries to
get in for an offensive foul and he
doesn't mean you
get [ __ ] anywhere close to an
offensive foul and they call the
offensive one [ __ ] uh
weber and i'll never forget whether they
showed it almost so much and he hands
the ball to the rest like this with his
face like this
yeah he just walked away it was
unbelievable it's such a bad job
oh my god i know that's another thing
too because i got to listen to the laker
fans say they have just as many as us
and they count one from the baa before
there was an nba they count that nba
title
they got one that's a [ __ ] you know a
mobbed up ref
helped them get and then then they got
all these pylon championships where free
agents come in because like
dude i'll admit it's a celtics fan 2008
was a pile on
yeah we built a team there but but other
than that kevin mchale was in the front
office of the timberwolves he gave us
garnett for nothing yeah
yeah i mean like i'm not gonna sit here
and act like we're innocent and all of
this
i'm just saying as a fan of professional
[ __ ] hoop
um but let's talk let's talk uh hockey
let's talk let's hope that [ __ ] the
penguins and just go to game seven
and beat the brains in so we get another
couple days of rest and then we'll
[ __ ] i think miller can come back
right
yeah i'm telling you matt i think uh how
about pasta how [ __ ] how much an
animal is he no they've all been i've
you know been with the kids and stuff so
i i caught
most of the series one of the games i
caught like only the third period
the one where miller got hurt i only
caught the third period of that one but
um we gotta watch this thing next next
series we gotta come up and watch we'll
get the guys
definitely but i really think that like
taylor hall
just the threat of him even though he's
only scored like a couple of goals or
whatever just the threat of that guy
and giving us two legit lines yep took
the pressure off
our our our top line and also caused the
other team to have to adjust their lines
where it's like you couldn't just
front end load our top line like you did
and also i think our fourth line with
wagner and those guys have been playing
[ __ ] great this year
yeah they're all i mean we're hitting on
all soldiers and you know
i think i i tell you what getting by the
capitals as much as you know
some people don't think they're as good
i i i think you know that's great that
we got by him so quickly too it's going
to give us
uh you know going forward penguins and
islanders
both make me know islanders i feel like
you know once we got taylor hall we
we've been beating them but i feel like
they kind of had our number all this
year
and then pittsburgh i think historically
yeah
historically speaking because they've
had people like mario lemieux and yeah
cosby malkin i mean like that [ __ ]
franchise dude with like the one-two
superstar punch that they not only did
you eat
you get lucky maybe you do it one time
the fact that they did that
twice within 20 years is
um i love [ __ ] like that like seeing
like
like how the um the green bay packers
went from brett favre
immediately to aaron rodgers yeah yeah
because like if you look at the dolphins
yeah you know they went bob greasy to
dan marino and then just
nothing [ __ ] yeah unbelievable still
waiting it's
hoping this kid from alabama with the
patriots [ __ ] works out because
it's like brady's gone yeah like when
does
this happen again belichick's almost 70.
yeah hey you know what i always say
don't cry for us we've had a good run i
hope it goes
i hope they can keep going you know what
i mean but uh you know i remember the
years and you do too i remember people
were sick of the patriots winning
i i go i remember we went like 20
somewhat years without a playoff game
i'm not sick of them winning you know
miami would come to town it was just how
bad they would [ __ ] beat us now uh
no i remember that we never went that
long but we we didn't go
deep we had like we had that great run
in 76 and then that roughing the passer
call against the raiders
yeah which is why i don't have sympathy
on the tuck rule that was the payback
yeah yeah you know they gave you the
game and then they gave us the game the
other [ __ ] way
but uh and everything else how about uh
jacksonville's got that kid uh what's
his name now lawrence
so uh they got him i like the guy they
had there with the mustache what the
[ __ ] his name
uh the second the season's over i forget
everybody's [ __ ] name but i i heard
mere mitchu
yeah gardner minshew yeah yeah
that kid i like that kid man i just like
the way he looks too he looks like a
[ __ ] quarterback like back in the day
all of those guys ken stable and all
that i had the beards and the mustaches
and [ __ ]
they just all looked like [ __ ] porn
stars back then so
um well before we get out of here dude i
i'm here in the avalanche man i'm
hearing the avalanche or uh
to joe bartnick yeah so yeah the west
the west is tough
i did enjoy seeing saint louis get swept
yeah yeah oh yeah there's no level off
there no there
isn't there isn't that [ __ ] [ __ ]
like [ __ ] nhl jesus christ letting
them play
night late 90s early 2000s hockey
dude they i will never get they beat the
bruins playing bruins hockey
running our
but you know i feel good for their fans
though speaking of which before we get
out here you know what i have been
watching
the [ __ ] maple leafs first the
canadians they're up three games to one
they're killing them i know
the last time they beat the canadians in
a playoff game was in 1967 the year
before i was born was the last time they
won the cup
jesus and they yeah but here's the thing
they hadn't played him in the playoffs
since 1980 they were in a different
conference for like almost 20
years so i've been kind of watching that
thing so they're
they're always my second team i root for
the bruins and then i root for the leafs
which is hilarious because the leaf fans
[ __ ] hate the bruins because of that
time we came back and beat him
yeah they don't hate us as much as the
habs haters so
but uh but i i tell you what then you
got the
vegas golden knights or just don't know
enough to not [ __ ] win you know it's
just it's crazy
you know is that kid reeves still on
that team i don't even know
75 man i was watching highlights of that
guys
huh and i was gonna go to one right
before the whole pandemic [ __ ] happened
i was gonna go
well when they first when they first
came out i think the first month they
were playing the bruins and i was gonna
go but i had a gig so i couldn't make it
and i was like i'll catch the bruins we
should do that dude
we could do it you know brian regan's
got tickets we can go with brian he's
got great he's got great seats there
he's like a little
mini sweet thing and uh that what a
production you know it's vegas so they
do
i guess you wouldn't believe the show
before the show yeah i saw at first i
didn't like it then i then i
was like no man it's vegas it's got to
be a show so it's like all right get it
i wish it had a little more viva las
vegas elvis to it yes
to me it looked like a minor league
hockey team trying to you know shoot
t-shirts into the crowd and stuff you
know
but it was like you know i got it like
the same thing i kind of acquiesced and
go
it's vegas you know whatever they do
they got to do something big you know
you know absolutely well listen dude i
can't i can't tell you dude
how much i learned from you as a
comedian coming up
and how happy i am not only you gotta
you got an acting road
acting role on uh louder milk you're
actually wrote a couple of episodes with
jimmy dunn
yeah yeah jimmy done the time we did
that [ __ ]
high s high school gig for matt malley
he told us it was a [ __ ] high school
game we showed up it was a [ __ ]
junior high
the kids voices hadn't even changed
they're all in the crowd like hey
[ __ ] i remember the principal did the
intro
this is how he did the intro he just
came walking on he just goes and we
are quiet please and he just started
[ __ ] yelling at him he's gonna give
him detention or something
i i've never gone out in front of a
crowd and had absolutely nothing to talk
about
but anyway i'm really happy for you
brother loudermilk
it's on amazon prime jackie is going to
be
at crackers in indianapolis on this
friday and saturday
may 28th 29th come out and see him
watch him down a few bud lights as he
makes you laugh your ass off
hey billy i can't if i if i if i could
just
tell my if they i i'm jay flynn comedy
on twitter and instagram if i could get
uh get that out there too
is it the letter j or j a y it's just j
flynn comedy
on on instagram and twitter i got a
jackie flynn fan page on facebook and
all that [ __ ]
so once again it's just the letter j
yeah j
just the letter j flynn comedy okay we
got it
all right jackie hey i love you i'm so
happy for your success
and uh i'm very very proud of you man
and thank you everybody
same hey let's uh let's smoke some
sticks and watch some bruins hockey soon
i look forward to it buddy be good all
right brother
all right all birds all birds everybody
you know it's finally getting
warm out and we're starting to feel more
hopeful about the rest of the year
it's time to get out there with all
birds lace up and feel good with all
birds and they're sustainably made
tree runner shoes perfect fit style
support and made from neutral materials
what's not to love all birds are not
just your average everyday shoes oh no
no no
um they will literally be your favorite
shoes to wear every day
once you get your hands on these tree
runners the tree runner's shoe is made
from sustainable
natural materials that feel light on
your feet and are better for the planet
i love companies that give a [ __ ] about
the planet
um even if they just say they do the
tree runners are breathable machine
washable
and made with responsible source
eucalyptus tree
fiber which probably means after they
chop the tree down they plant another
one
simple and versatile design makes the
tree runner a perfect too
perfect to go shoe for any outfit
responsibly source eucalyptus tree fiber
for a comfy
breathable upper um sugarcane based
sweet foam
tm midsoles made with the first carbon
negative
eva resin this is [ __ ] great man i
think this is the direction products are
going to have to go
packaging made from 90 recycled
cardboard
that's a shoebox shopping bag and mailer
all in one
um this spring keep things light and
breezy with all birds tree runner i'm
gonna check these things out
discover your perfect pair at
allbirds.com today
that's all birds a-l-l-b-i-r-d-s
dot-com oh look who it is everybody it's
all zip
are you hiring this spring is that what
you're doing what type of role are you
hiring for
maybe you need to hire someone to wear
many hats which can be challenging or
you might have a simple position to feel
feel to fill
but it's taking forever to find someone
who has a great fit for you
and your company uh that's where
ziprecruiter comes in
zip recruiter can help you find quality
candidates fast and now you can try it
for free at zip
dot com burp whether you need to hire a
civil engineer in new york
uh i thought it said a pathetic nurse a
pediatric nurse
i need a pathetic nurse stat pediatric
nurse in nebraska an attorney in
colorado
colorado even a mascot in missouri
uh zip recruiters matching technology
finds people with the right experience
for your job
and actively invites them to apply
um it's so effective that four out of
five who post on zipper crew get a
quality candidate within the first day
from account accountant to zoologist and
everything in between
makes hiring easier and right now you
can try for free
at our list our at our only our
listeners get it
link ziprecruiter.com
uh to try zip recruiter for free we get
credit for sending you oh meaning me
i want you guys how awful am i at this
one now you can actually see me doing
this i'm getting like self-conscious
once again that's it
dot com slash birth spell out bur
b-u-r-r
all right what do i got left oh one more
mercifully one more
roman everybody hey guys we got big news
your favorite men's
healthcare brand roman is now available
at walmart
wally world roman's non-prescription
products have got you covered with
everything from
sexual health to everyday health your
well-being is important
and taking care of it should be simple
so now you can add to
now so now you can add to cart irl
these kids with their [ __ ] phrases i
don't even know what half the stuff
means roman
now what's that in real life
oh irl oh url in real life okay
so now you can add two cards in real
life
irl is that big that [ __ ] i was
supposed to know that
roman now available at walmart oh good
brick and mortar store
uh we're in your area let's go take care
of it
sexual health roman condoms are new and
exclusive to walmart
um you won't find them anywhere else
designed ultra thin lubricated for
pleasure
and fda cleared because safe sex is sexy
over-the-counter medication also known
as otc
roman swipes are an easy discreet way to
delay ejaculation
increase sexual stamina they're fast
acting and your partner will enjoy them
too
no passed along desensitization um
if you use as intended yeah so if you're
slapping on your dick there and you go
to put it in somebody
that they don't go out are you doing
something because i don't feel it
it immediately i don't know the numbness
goes into your your member
i hope i explained that that wasn't too
scientific uh
dietary supplement dr dr formulated with
nutrients roman daily is a multivitamin
that is optimized
with ingredients to support men's health
and overall well-being roman's team
of in-house doctors created this unique
high quality supplement to target
nutrition gaps in men with
scientifically backed ingredients and
dosages
ate too much remember supplements are
not a replacement for a healthy diet
exercise or good sleep
you've still got to eat your greens and
get your steps in visit your local
walmart store today and check out
roman's line of men's healthcare
products
that's roman roman men's healthcare
products at walmart
do it today live a better life have a
great weekend
once again the great jackie flynn please
enjoy the music
picked out this week by uh the amazing
andrew themeless and we'll have a bonus
episode of the thursday afternoon just
before friday
monday morning podcast after this
wonderful music all right
see
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast
for monday um may 27th
2013. i don't like the way i just said
um
monday um you ever catch yourself
sounding like a douche there
happy memorial day happy memorial day
a beautiful time to thank the troops and
stuck you
stuff your [ __ ] face with [ __ ]
right isn't that what you're doing let's
all have a moment of silence for
everyone who made a sacrifice for this
country
all right let's go stuff our faces right
there's no way it doesn't know what
every [ __ ] holiday is
flag day today is a day
to remember remember remember all the
flags
that have waves all above this country
god big questions
and alice stuff our faces faces faces
let's get drunk and have a fight with
our mother's mother's mother's
you know isn't that what it is how many
people are actually going to go to a
[ __ ] parade today
from the halls of montezuma
to the shores of triple e huh
who can sing beyond that [ __ ]
two lines other than a goddamn ex-marine
or a current marine one or the other
is that what they do when when you when
you join the marines by the way
do you have to sing that song as some
drill sergeant
is in your face i don't hate you
you're [ __ ] screaming
[ __ ] they're singing like one of
them queers
right i commend anybody who's in the
military service simply for the ability
to get through boot camp
and having somebody screaming in your
face and just pushing down
every ounce of your being to not like
just
punch that guy right in the [ __ ] face
this is the thing like i've thought
about that [ __ ] right
like let's say things get really [ __ ]
up and all of a sudden they they want to
draft
soon to be 45 year old balding redheads
like myself
and i've actually thought about for some
reason
i think i think about it whenever i do
pull-ups because whenever i do pull-ups
i always
climb the rope i always think you think
i could make it through [ __ ]
maybe three obstacles three obstacles
in one of those boot camp things i could
get up the [ __ ] rope
i probably couldn't do the required
amount of pull-ups
but i wonder if i could just get out of
the drill sergeant you know i still
think you're a queer
but i'm impressed with your upper body
strike and you're right you get the [ __ ]
out my face
right could at least get one of those
but my thing is if someone was screaming
in my ear like that
like i got tinnitus or tetanus however
the [ __ ] you say
i have it in one of my ears so if the
guy's screaming in my ears i'd have to
be like yes excuse me uh i just
you know i not trying to not be marine
like but i just want to let you know
that i i
played a lot of drums and uh my uh ears
they're very sensitive if you could just
uh you know you can continue with the
insults i'm not trying to tell you how
to do your job but if you could just
somehow bring the volume down
you know then immediately i'm pile
because everybody else has to start
doing push-ups
is this quiet enough for your private
bur
look at the rest of your platoon sitting
here
doing push-ups because you don't want me
to yell too loud
just exactly how quiet do you think war
is
you red-headed freckled [ __ ] [ __ ]
right doesn't know what the thing to say
to you it's always the homophobic [ __ ]
isn't that what they come at you with
huh i bet you're sucking dick
[Laughter]
you know what i actually shouldn't say
any of this because i have no idea what
they say to you
other than what i've watched in movies
you know so anyways
happy memorial day a beautiful time
to thank the troops and stuff you
[ __ ] faced with some [ __ ]
um that should be the official memorial
day
i think the only people who truly
appreciate it are people who have
actually
served and know people who have served
you know that would be my really built
do you really think that the people who
are closest to it appreciate it the most
what other groundbreaking things are you
gonna say in this podcast
oh i know i know i'm a [ __ ] all right
can you just let me have my moment
can you well all right then
um i'm in new york city right now
i'm in my old apartment
lonely as [ __ ] i don't know how i used
to do this as a single man
you know although i have to tell you
it's um you guys know the comedian not
ted alexandra if you don't you should
he's one of the best [ __ ] comics out
there
he used to have this great joke i'll
just do the gist of it because i don't
want to [ __ ] burn you he used to just
say that basically
if it was essentially that you know
being single it sucked at night
because you were lonely but it was great
for the rest of the day
i can't say i'm feeling that but i do
have to i have to concur with that joke
that at night time when you [ __ ] go
home
by yourself that's when it gets to you i
think cause when you wake up in the
morning you have errands to run you
gotta i'm gonna go to the gym
you know there's hope that's what it is
there's hope that you're gonna find
somebody
you know when at night all that hope is
gone and it's just
you a pine ice cream and a slice of
pizza
you know slowly crying as you're crying
softly as you're chewing
getting down to the crust
[Music]
um actually you know i i've um
i've made a rule that this time when i
go through new york i'm not having any
pizza and i'm not having any ice cream
and i know what you're thinking
bill you're in new york city you have to
have the pizza okay
well i'm gonna tell you what i've had
enough
new york pizza to last me a [ __ ]
lifetime first of all
90 of new york pizza sucks a giant
pizza [ __ ] because it doesn't make any
sense um does make sense
simply because there's so many people
living off the [ __ ] reputation
that new york has great pizza you know
that's the problem new york does have
great pizza but there's no laws
prohibiting anybody from opening a pizza
shop
saying the best pizza in new york city
you know it's [ __ ] horrific
maybe if i do danger fields i'll go over
to that sutton pizza there over on first
avenue i always liked that pizza had a
nice [ __ ] zip over there a nice zip
to the sauce there a nice little tang
there nice little
what the [ __ ] was that there in their uh
and their pizza slices you know
i don't know pizza's always that [ __ ]
you're like stumbling home after a
couple two three [ __ ] whiskeys right
and then you [ __ ] uh i don't know
what
i think what the hell i'm saying i
realized i have to get a [ __ ]
appointment book because i just realized
how much [ __ ] i just planned for
tomorrow
you know i'm gonna get a steak [ __ ]
dinner
with joey roses and keith robinson
somebody over at the stand comedy club
the head chef over there is going to
teach me how to make a [ __ ] pizza pie
over there um
because i got the big green egg and i
can heat that [ __ ] up to 700 degrees
do you guys even know what i'm talking
about
just realize that i bought this this big
green egg this
barbecuer and a smoker and they give you
this book showing you all the wonderful
[ __ ] that you can make on it and all
i've made on it is burgers hot dog and
[ __ ] chicken
so i want to take it to the next level i
want to be able to make a pizza but you
got to know how to make your own
[ __ ] dough you know
which i don't know how to do so i'm
going to have this person show me how to
do it
because i'm a [ __ ] singer right
i'm always trying something new oh
what's that what's that bill up to the
[ __ ] today anyways
how about those bruins huh here we go
bruins here we go
that's how it used to be that's the
chant that used to get going back in the
days in the old boston garden
now they go let's go bruins i'm telling
you
that's the ranger champ it was here we
go bruins here we go and let's go
rangers
all right well you know where the
rangers are going now out to the [ __ ]
golf course
because yes the bruins in one short week
went to the [ __ ] mecca
madison square garden in
five games it was actually a five game
sweep who's kidding who
you know not to take anything away from
the rangers but i'm gonna all right
when the whole rally on your side gets
going because our goalie
fell down i whenever you have a goalie
he just
falls down like some kid playing peewee
hockey and then he tried to go oh there
was a
rut in the ice ah you fell down took
it's okay it happens to the best of us
go down to a public rink you see it all
the time
my favorite thing in a public rink is
watching that guy when it takes like 12
seconds for him to fall
right the [ __ ] six
going backwards six going forwards right
and then the [ __ ]
that whip bam
and it's usually the back hits first and
then the [ __ ] whiplash and then the
head makes that nice hollow coconut
puke right off the [ __ ] ice that
unmistakable sound
of somebody squash hitting a sheet of
ice
that's a [ __ ] that's an incredible sound
you know what and i don't think that
that can be reproduced by hollywood
unless you actually had somebody slam
their head on it that's incredible
not even with one of those casio
keyboards that has access to over a
thousand sound effects they never have
do you ever notice that they never have
the sound effect of a head
hitting the asphalt or uh or a sheet of
ice
so there's one few nerds why isn't
somebody out there
you know one of you photoshop [ __ ] out
there try to get me
up the perfect that perfect sound effect
and set it to me and i'll have my first
sound effect on the podcast
you know and i'll turn this into a wacky
morning show and every time i say
something dumb i go oh what was i
thinking and then i'll click the button
and then you'll hear it and then you
laugh
and then you'll be in the parking lot of
your job
holding onto the steering wheel ten and
two just staring at that front door that
you don't want to walk through
just having those last few moments to
yourself
thinking about all the decisions you
made over the last 12 years
why did i break up with her why did i
major in this
why did i buy this car
why can't i feel feelings anymore
as your eyes well up with tears you just
look up at the heavens wonder if there's
some old guy up there that gives a [ __ ]
you cry softly
and then for some unexplained reason you
look over to the left
and this there's your boss staring at
you
with this weird look on his face like
is that mike crying in his [ __ ] car
she quickly try to play it off like you
sneeze you take a big deep breath
and you push all those [ __ ] feelings
down you like it and you get out of the
car hey boy
hey boss how you doing and i allergies
allergies oh yeah i'll see you in there
yep can't wait
um sorry anyways so the bruins
are now going to go play the the
the most confusing franchise
in uh in in um in nhl uh in the nhl
i don't know how to feel about the
[ __ ] penguins i totally respect them
and i'm [ __ ] blown away by their
ability
to somehow always get the guy that's the
next guy
i mean it's insane like the last 20
years
25 years i would actually put them
beyond the yankees
yeah wait a minute or i would i would no
i would compare them to the yankees
um when that when when the yankees
you know got uh babe ruth then lou
gehrig then joe dimaggio
mickey mantle i would actually that this
is the closest thing you've seen well
they
the penguins mario lemieux
um cindy crosby and [ __ ]
geno malkin i don't know how to say this
and denny i don't know how to [ __ ]
say these hockey names nowadays
i used to be jacques and all these
french [ __ ] names that was easy right
michelle goulet
um
[ __ ] four absolute snipers i mean
unbelievable [ __ ] top-notch goddamn
players
it's incredible right they have that
and then on the other side right and
then whenever they get hit they're like
you know mario lemusley
you know if people don't stop cheating
i'm not gonna play anymore
right yogurt was always like oh he's got
a mullet and he just loves those kit
kats
hates them all the time some people play
that's why you know
he's scoring all those goals i'll tell
you i wish i knew that when i played
all right sidney crosby
big pouty lipped [ __ ] cub scout that
he is you know
what's the hate about that guy other
than the fact
that you know he doesn't do anything
wrong in life
helping old people cross the street even
with the skates on runs out of the arena
is that an old person trying to cross
the street just a [ __ ]
wheaties cereal box cover looking son of
a [ __ ]
why is he a son of a [ __ ] because you
know he's better than you
head and shoulders the best [ __ ] guy
in the league
then he got mark a guy who could be a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
and be like hey what about me he doesn't
give a [ __ ]
he just plays his goddamn game and it's
tremendous
all right it's a great [ __ ] hockey
town
they had one of the great last arenas
that melon arena carnegie mellon heinz
whatever the [ __ ] they called it
goddamn pittsburgh people they got three
names for everything see the heinz
carnegie carnegie mellon or just melon
i guess that's four but it's really just
carnegie mellon just all [ __ ] remix
like p diddy's in there by the way
the more years that goes by that biggie
has been dead and his legend just keeps
growing and growing with the fact that
nobody's ever matched that guy's ability
with humor storytelling and being able
to paint a [ __ ] picture
forget about his charisma this last time
you saw a guy even remotely with the
[ __ ] charisma of that guy
all right as the years go by and you
keep going back
frustrated with the new [ __ ] and you
just keep going back to that
that mumbling [ __ ] [ __ ]
that puffy does on every [ __ ] track
it's it's like is can somebody out there
send me some [ __ ] biggie tracks where
you you removed
puffy going that's right uh-huh
okay in the [ __ ] background whatever
the [ __ ] he says
or just repeats every god the last word
of every line that biggie says it's like
we heard it
wasn't it enough for you to be in there
with the [ __ ] faders
pushing those up and down i gotta listen
to your mumbling jackass
i tell you one of the worst [ __ ] rap
songs ever was when he
and that other mumbling jacket mace
tell me who's hot who's not tell me who
you guys
do you know what tell me which one of
you is [ __ ] rapping because i can't
tell
why am i this upset anyways
let's let's let's dial it down let's
dial it down let's get back to the
[ __ ]
to the that's back okay
i'm agreeing with him um
ah [ __ ] so that's one side of the
penguins and then on the other side
of the penguin and you know crosby [ __ ]
moaning and complaining
mario lemieux [ __ ] moaning and
complaining about the thuggery the
cheating and all that [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then like right in their own goddamn
locker room
they have had the exact same thing where
you had the
ruth dimaggio mickey mantle lou gehrig
they've had that
of the [ __ ] biggest goddamn knee
breakers
cheating sons of [ __ ] ever
you know i i have this love hate with
the penguins
you know i love them because i respect
the franchise and i hate them
because not because they have these
cheating [ __ ] that [ __ ] just go out
there and try and end people's careers
it's the fact that they then have the
balls
to [ __ ] you know that's the kind of
hockey the islanders are gonna play i
mean i don't
know why we're even in this league
[Music]
meanwhile you got [ __ ] matt cook in
35 years
of watching people play hockey i've
never seen a guy
check somebody in the boards and
accidentally completely
sever the guy's [ __ ] achilles tendon
how does that happen i don't know
they say it was a [ __ ] accident and
if it was anybody else i would have
believed it
you know what the sad thing about matt
cook is is a guy can actually play he's
a
[ __ ] great player and he's definitely
toned down his [ __ ] but i mean i can't
ever forgive the guy because he ended
savart's career
guys on a follow-through of a [ __ ]
shot
could not be more vulnerable you come by
30 miles an hour
and hit him with that plastic shoulder
blade with pad which is like hitting
somebody across the jaw with the [ __ ]
wrench and you end his goddamn career
unbelievable i'm [ __ ] so this is
going to be uh
this is gonna be a brutal series um
the only [ __ ] weak part i can see on
the uh
penguins is the they have shaky
goaltending
you know but just their offensive power
i just um
i don't know my heart says bruins but if
i was putting money on it
i mean i would say penguins at six i
know there's a lot of bruins fans doing
what the [ __ ] were you [ __ ] shanking
where you were you
you [ __ ] getting all weird now that
you're living out [ __ ] l.a dude
no i just watch enough hockey and i've
seen what the [ __ ] they're capable of
like cindy crosby is literally
unstoppable
you know unfucking stoppable and if they
just had one guy like that you know like
the capitals
and ovechkin's nowhere near uh crosby
although he had a great year
um now i'm gonna have those guys [ __ ]
whining to me
he won the scoring title um
you know we want if he just [ __ ] had
him but the fact that you have all those
other guys
you know malkin and all those guys
it's not it's gonna be [ __ ]
i don't know how you i you know what i'm
calling it right now we're gonna play
the trap we're gonna try and play that
boring ass [ __ ] hockey
and it's gonna kill me i'm gonna have to
watch because it's my t
but i want before anybody sends me the
emails no
i don't enjoy watching it even if we win
a game i don't like it because uh
i really enjoyed watching the uh penguin
senators
series even though that one last game
was a that seven goal game was a [ __ ]
was a blowout um oh by the way
once again you know a lot of people
explained to me why there was such
hatred towards uh
maple leaf fans toronto in general and
all that type of thing and everybody was
saying that basically
that's the biggest city in canada
and that's where like all the media is
so
because all the media is there it's like
everybody in toronto then thinks the
whole [ __ ] country or the whole world
revolves around them i'm not saying it's
true i'm an outsider but that's what
they say but it reminded me kind of
kind of of like like new yorkers you
know what i mean
like they just think everything begins
and [ __ ] ends
you know with like man the only reason
madison square garden is this
mecca is because it's in the middle of
the biggest [ __ ] city
with all this media here you know and a
lot of new yorkers they really
confuse that it's a mecca that's just a
gathering place
people come and play hoop there because
that's where they can make the most
amount of [ __ ] money
and get the most amount of meaty
exposure but that has nothing to do
with the knicks or how good
or the the legendary the knicks are not
legendary
they're not all right
with spike lee sitting courtside you're
[ __ ] low rent jack nicholson
oh woody allen with this awful hat
jesus christ you know
at least la they have the decency to get
their faces laminated
if you're gonna be the celebrity sitting
on the side i'm just [ __ ] with you
anyway so
the knicks are out the rangers are out
because of the boston bruins and uh
once again the garden is silent and it's
ready for the circus
the mecca that's their [ __ ]
that's what happens every goddamn yeah
do you realize the rangers have won one
stanley cup in the last 73 [ __ ] years
you understand that
do you realize that in like the [ __ ]
60-something years
that the nba has been around the uh
new york knicks have won only two titles
two titles last one they won was in 1973
oh let's do the math on that one that
was 40 [ __ ] years ago
that's why version kills me dude the
garden was rocking last night he's
always telling me how loud the garden is
i'm [ __ ] believable really
okay louder than the [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ]
tdf xyz garden whatever the [ __ ] they
call the boston garden now
when the bruins came back down [ __ ]
three goals in a game seven was it
louder than that paul versi
i'm asking you um
all right you're listening to the monday
morning podcast here everybody jeez
louise you know what i think it's time
to tell you guys about some wonderful
products
that you might not have been aware of
all right here's one for you
the dollar shave club getting a good
shave can be a real pain in the ass
um searching through 50 brands matching
new blades to old handles
[ __ ] features where your razor
doubles as a flashlight
vibrator toothpick 20 bucks for new
razors that really is a rip
off by the way the new razer blades i
love they have them behind a case
you know like they're giving you gold
coins it's like maybe if you didn't
charge 80 bucks for each one
you wouldn't have to [ __ ] lock them
up um
but anyways uh go to dollarshaveclub.com
to get high quality
raises delivered to your door for just a
couple of bucks a month
they've made it simple high quality
razors 100
guaranteed sent on schedule so you never
have to think about it ever again
every month you get a new pack and every
week you change your blade
and it costs a fraction of what you'd
pay at retail
plus you don't have to stand in line um
i want you to try it
give it a shot let me know what you
think go to dollarshaveclub.com forward
slash
burr b-u-r-r you'll get a free sample of
dr carvey's easy shave
butter which is awesome with uh
your first shipment also make the pr it
also makes the perfect father's day gift
gift come on bill hang in there dollar
shave club
something he can actually use uh support
this show go to dollarshaveclub.com
forward slash bur or click on the dollar
shave club banner
on the podcast page at billberg.com
all right hula plus everybody you've
tried streaming hit shows on your pc
on now it's time to start your free
trial
of exclusive content in in your living
room
and on your mobile devices on hula plus
with hula plus
you get total control to watch thousands
of shows whenever you want
wherever you want use hula plus on
connected tvs game consoles blu-ray
players
roku is that how you say it apple tv pc
or watch from anywhere on your
smartphone or tablet
on demand at all times even on a plane
can i do this on a plane
um anyways and with hulu plus you can
binge on full seasons watch your
favorite current shows and even or even
full series runs of classic tv shows
it's endless
actually you could do this on a plane
because now you can get wi-fi
god damn it this is unbelievable we're
in the future here everybody
they've got community modern family
south park snl monday night raw the man
show
jimmy kimmel family guy and more feel
free
to check it out in your own time hula
plus is only 7.99 per month
but right now they're offering an
extended free trial of hula plus
that is only available to podcast
listeners take control of your tv
watching experience
go to the podcast page at billboard.com
click the hulu plus banner for extent
for an extended free trial
or go to huluplus.com bill again
the hulu plus banner on the podcast page
at billboard.com
or go to huluplus.com bill
and we got one more for you e-voice
everybody
e-voice is the reason you're gonna make
more money in
when your customers call you'll have
your own toll-free number
professional greeting dial by name
directory and more
you'll sound you'll sound like a fortune
500 company and blow away your
competitors
e-voice lets you give out one number
that rings wherever you are
the beach the bar doesn't matter you'll
sound like you're at the office
you gotta go to e-voice and use the
promo code bill
um e-voice takes all your voicemails
transcribes them and sends them to you
instantly as a text mail so you can
check your voicemails before the meeting
ends and not even look rude
evoice is only 10 bucks a month right
now listeners
to my podcast get a free trial of
e-voice for 30 days
so check it out stop what you're doing
hit pause set up your e-voice free trial
and see what i'm talking about it's a
great way to support my podcast and an
easy way to make more money this year
i hope you guys all do it go to
evoice.com promo code bill
that's evoice dot com promo code bill or
just go to the podcast page
billboard.com and click on the e-voice
banner
right now all right there you go
see that helping you shave better
helping you watch tv better helping you
get your [ __ ] business going
you know i'm hoping you leave me behind
someday i'll be reading an ad for your
company there hey
let's get let's keep talking with the
sports here all right who's kidding who
i don't watch that much nba hoop i don't
i really
i like it i know i [ __ ] on it a lot but
uh
i gotta tell you that dwyane wade flying
[ __ ] elbow
all right now it did look like he was
trying to leap over the guy
but at the last second there was no
[ __ ] reason to do what he did
it was like a wrestling move and i know
it's debatable but what
killed me was reggie miller and the
other commentator
or steve kerr immediately
the first reviewing of it just go yeah
that wasn't intentional at all
that's that you know it's it's part of
the natural
bodily movement when you leap into the
air like one of your elbows just sticks
out like that
to give somebody a forearm shiver he
[ __ ] gave the guy
an impromptu flying elbow
that's what i think yeah he leapt in the
air you know because they were kind of
crossing over each other in a weird way
he jumped over the guy
and was like oh there's his head yeah
how about you [ __ ] right there fred
how do you like they gave one of those
the guy collapses in a [ __ ] heat
although i heard he's known for flopping
but it just killed me that just
automatically just oh yeah yeah
holy [ __ ] look at that elbow oh wait
that's one of the superstars of the
league
you know i don't think that there was
anything uh premeditated uh there was no
malicious act
of just it's ridiculous
if that happened to dwyane wade and he
went down
i swear to god both of them would it be
like see now that that right there
that's the kind of thing that just does
not belong
in this game at this level or or at any
level for that matter you know i mean
there's kids at home watching this game
i mean that's just
look at that let's watch this again i
mean oh that's just disgraceful that's
just
i mean just premeditated i'll tell you
the league's got to take a look at this
and uh i would be really surprised if
that gentleman was playing
the next uh the next contest
superstar does it yeah you know he
didn't mean anything by that you know
he's kind of uh
he was in the air he had to flap his
wings like a bird you know he doesn't
have any feathers so he's got to tuck
his his
his hands back towards his torso it's
very normal very normal right there
um that's it that's all i know about
hoop this week
other than i'm pulling for the paces who
else is playing who's out in the west
i love you know what i love i love the
spurs and their white guy basketball
that they play
i absolutely love they're fundamentally
sound
pick and roll [ __ ] kiss it off the
glass
i can't jump either game that they play
it's tremendous
there's not a lot of white guys out
there doing it but when i when i watch
the spurs play that's it looks like
five white guys playing pickup at the y
and
it's effective i don't know how they do
it
so who are they playing they're playing
the grizzlies
um i don't give a [ __ ] i'm just so
elated that the lakers aren't in it
so [ __ ] elated absolutely love it and
i hope dwight howard stays
with the lakers the same way i have
enjoyed
um what's his face alex rodriguez
staying
with the new york yankees alex rodriguez
is my most favorite yankee
of all [ __ ] time you know
as they try to shame him out of town and
he's just like yeah you know
you know you want me to sit down in a
playoff game i don't give a [ __ ]
i'm not leaving that contract go [ __ ]
yourselves i'm staying
i love it i absolutely love it
um i actually watched a really
disturbing uh youtube video last night i
i'm trying to think of how the hell i
got there
i was watching animals and i was
watching these two little
[ __ ] weird things they can't see that
well
their heartbeat when they're nervous can
go up to like 1300 beats
per minute you know
like somebody trying to win one of those
fastest hands single stroke rolled drum
contest
they [ __ ] they can beat them with
with their heart
they can't see that well
and i don't know they basically they
have to live meal to meal their
heartbeat so [ __ ] fast
that if they miss a meal they could
actually die
the sleuth of sloth i don't know what
the [ __ ] this thing was but all i know
they don't see that well and they they
two of them don't see each other till
they literally
run into each other i gotta find this
[ __ ] video
and they just had this the sickest
fight i've ever seen in my life like
they had to slow it down
like when they were showing it they're
going this is not sped up footage
this is how fast these guys was like
watching two flyweights
times like you know to the fifth power
so i'm watching that [ __ ] which leads to
more [ __ ] and then i see like these
these
these bloodhounds getting fed
doing all that [ __ ] next thing and you
know you just can you just keep looking
to the right
it's more you know eagles killing snakes
snakes killing [ __ ] this
a mongoose killing a [ __ ] uh
black mamba and then next thing you know
i'm watching these rednecks
going bear hunting right
and they got all these dogs in these
metal cages and they can stick their
[ __ ]
heads out and it's hilarious they stick
their heads out and go
[Music]
right and all the pita people are of
course like they're saying i want to get
out of this cage
they're really excited because they want
to go [ __ ] hunting because what i'm
what i'm
thinking they're doing so i'm like
they're going to hunt these bears
with dogs what the [ __ ] is this i mean a
bear could just swat one of them
kill him but what it is is they have so
many of them and basically
the dogs go they chase the bear
the bear goes up a tree and then like 10
rednecks walk up to the tree
and then one of them decides all right
i'll [ __ ] shoot it
and they shoot it and it falls out of
the [ __ ] tree it's just the worst
thing i've ever seen in my life
just as far as like listen going bear
hunting
takes unbelievable [ __ ] balls
if it's you and a buddy
you know and you're in bear country
and you could stumble upon a grizzly
bear that's that she's walking with her
cubs and then she immediately comes over
and tries to rip your [ __ ] face off
and even though you got a gun that still
takes an unbelievable amount of balls
but i gotta tell you this
hunting black bear with like [ __ ] ten
dogs
five dogs and they chase it up a tree
and then you show up watch this
i'm gonna shoot that thing that's the
size of my garage
[ __ ] nailed it man it was it was
[ __ ] disgusting
it was really disgusting
i respect it on one level because you
have an ability to live off the land
the dollar crashes you're like well we
didn't have anything in the stock market
[ __ ] it let's go bear hunt
you know because those people really are
the ones who are going to survive
so i have such a tremendous respect for
anybody who hunts
and has the ability to
go out and and basically go get some
food
unlike me he's a total [ __ ] and just
goes down to the [ __ ]
grocery store yeah can i get a pound of
omega three quarters a pound off the
turkey do you have the smoke let me get
the smoked turkey
some harvarte cheese with that i'd like
that right
that's me hunting and i get frustrated
when i can't find the cereal aisle
so i'm basically one of the guys who
when the [ __ ] hits the fan
you know and i'm in a city and i just
get [ __ ] heard into some goddamn fema
camp i'm done
avenge me i'm done right those rednecks
will just [ __ ] back
slowly back off of their property
like that dude who tuck his package
between his legs in that movie with that
chick
who was in the [ __ ] pinball movie
right silence of the lambs
and just slowly [ __ ] back out right
into the woods and you never see him
again
they're gonna be able to live off the
land and [ __ ] ride it out and they'll
create a new clan
you know and they'll be the ones that
eventually topple over the bankers
after they exterminate everybody and
they take all the land
and they'll laugh at those rednecks you
know and just call them a pesky problem
they'll try to hunt them down with
drones from their [ __ ] villas
those [ __ ] rednecks they're going to
be out there covered in mud like rambo a
little bit of deer urine behind their
necks
you know and eventually they're gonna
come back like [ __ ] attila the hun
and all empires fall and it's gonna be
those [ __ ] rednecks who do it
tremendous respect from okay now i
haven't said all of that
chasing a [ __ ] bear up a tree with a
bunch of goddamn dogs and just did you
just see the bear up there like
things just up there like dude are you
[ __ ] kidding me
you know it's it's it's not like
chilling but it's not totally upset it's
like all right i'm up a tree
i don't really know what those things
are they're very loud there's a lot of
them
but they don't seem to be able to climb
up the tree so eventually they'll get
tired they'll get thirsty they'll leave
i'll climb down you know crack open a
keystone and have a paw full of honey
and i'll just
you know that'll be my day then all of a
sudden these [ __ ]
you know just a good old boy these
[ __ ] guys just come
walking up and i'm telling you they're
literally standing like
maybe 20 yards from the tree and this
giant furry bean bag is right up there
and they've just shoot it in the neck
and then it just falls and they always
they don't
edit out it fallen out of the [ __ ]
tree
that's just it was just a uh i don't
know
any rednecks out here listening to this
where you can defend
i don't know that just seems like the uh
the tiddlywinks of [ __ ] uh
hunting you know checkers not chess
you know what i mean to quote denzel in
one of his uh movies where he screams at
the [ __ ] white guy from the suburbs
he doesn't quite you know was in over
his head right
teaching him the slang um
all right so like i mentioned i'm here
in new york city and uh i had a great
time last night i went down to uh
the comedy cellar and did like three
shows
down there and it reminded me of the old
days when i used to do all the shows
here in new york and [ __ ] jumping
cavs and zip back and forth between the
clubs
you'd have a new joke and you get to try
it three times in one night you just
can't
uh you can't put a price tag on that i
ran into ari shafir who was living in
l.a he's now in new york city
um and he's working his way into the
club he told me last night he's going to
start being leaving a veil so you can
check out ari shafir hopefully
on some upcoming shows and uh
i'm psyched for psyched to watch him
grow by leaps and bounds by getting all
that uh that extra stage time
so it's been a uh wonderful thing out
here oh i know what you know i forgot to
bring up
um the toronto mayor
can you guys give me some more
information on that guy they're trying
to say that he was smoking crack and he
goes uh he goes that
there's a video of him smoking crack he
said it doesn't exist
then he called the media a bunch of
maggots so so immediately i i'm loving
this guy
he's talking all this [ __ ] but then i
kind of read up on him
and he's got a lot of sketchy [ __ ] in
the background
i was wondering what you people in
toronto think about the guy
or in neighboring cities do you think he
is a piece of [ __ ]
do you think uh the media is a bunch of
maggots i don't [ __ ] know
let me know anyways here we go bill
as a penguins fans i have to ask do you
endorse the bruins pa announcer going
after goals if so what is wrong with you
um i have to admit i hated it when i
first heard it
i hated it absolutely [ __ ] hated it
and uh but i've come to an acceptance
but that the bruins aren't mine anymore
i'm an old man now
and uh it's on to the younger generation
and this is how they're doing it
and uh i got to admit now when i watch
the games
it's the playoffs and they score i'm so
[ __ ] excited that when the guy goes
whoa
i [ __ ] do it too and i feel like
[ __ ] ric flair
and it's and it's you can call me a
douche all day long and you'd be 100
right it's i can't even defend it
and if it wasn't my team i would be
trashing the [ __ ] out of it too
i really would all right well let me ask
you this
you guys have off samuel sing alf sam
you sing off samuelson in your ring of
honor
okay let me ask you what's worse
all right and i know what you're gonna
say you're gonna say the woo
because you don't give a [ __ ] you don't
give a [ __ ] because he's not [ __ ]
blowing out the knees of sydney crosby
but i can guarantee
you cried like a [ __ ] [ __ ] when
crosby was out for a year and a half
because that guy gave him a concussion
right and when mario lemieux was
bitching about the [ __ ]
islanders you probably like yeah that's
right mario that's exactly right
you know so here i am
trashing something that my own [ __ ]
team does why don't you grow up
and have the ability to do the same if
not go [ __ ] yourself
okay a few weeks ago i asked you know
when when you go to a casino
you know what's the deal with the
[ __ ] carpets
like why they have the ugliest carpets
on the planet
my theory has always been a casino was
so goddamn big the amount of money
that you will save by buying the ugliest
[ __ ] carpet on the cheap
um you know that's why you do it when
you literally i mean how many square
feet
is is like you know the mirage how many
square feet is the [ __ ]
bellagio and all that i mean i mean it
has to be
i have no idea i have no [ __ ] idea
a million square feet i have no [ __ ] i
mean how many trucks
have to pull up with that goddamn
carpeting so that's why i thought
that it was the other there was always
ugly carpeting so here's some theories
that people have said to me
um hey bill wanted to
to let you know in response to your five
your may 20th
podcast from having worked in the casino
industry
i've heard the reason the carpets in the
casino are so vomit inducingly
ugly is so people will avoid looking at
them
and instead look up at all the slot
machines
restaurant signage merchandise and
whatnot it's a psychological
manipulation to focus your attention
where they want it
there's also usually a confusing pattern
to the carpet
uh to the pattern uh wait this
is also usually a confusing pattern to
the carpet design
and overall structural layout to the
place
to make you subconsciously wander around
and put your money into something rather
than having any clue where an exit
might be or how how much time is passed
um i agree with that
i would agree with the second half the
first half i don't know
how long would you stare at carpet you
know
like god look at the fiber look how
look how beautiful that carpet is um i
would actually think at this point if
you had a beautiful carpet like a nice
[ __ ]
electric blue you know letting people
feel like oh my god something exciting
is going to happen here you know maybe a
piece something peaceful
maybe you'd be a little more relaxed
when you [ __ ] walked in there then
you could look around at the horse
i don't know but as far as like having
it a confusing pattern
and a weird structural layout i mean if
you've ever been
if you've never been lost in a casino
you've never been in a casino
what you end up having to do is you got
to pick like a you got to start
memorizing where the restaurants are
like there's where the sports book is
so i know the elevator is to the right
but if you start cutting through slots
and
you're like [ __ ] oh another jack
nicholson reference him in the shining
in the end wonder
as you're going through all those hedges
you're not
like i'm surprised you don't see
somebody sitting on the ground
like dead with an axe in their hand not
frozen
but you know you're frozen like those
people you pass when you're trying to
get to the top of that mountain there
mount everest right over there in the
himalayas is it in the himalayas i have
no idea
here's another theory somebody has the
strange pattern of the carpeting
on casino floors is so if you drop a
chip
you don't hear it hit the floor
and the crazy colors hide the chips if
you're looking for them
um i don't buy that one either that just
seems like a [ __ ]
long way to go to try and make some
money you're already playing a game
where the odds are so in favor of the
casino
they don't need to be crawling around
the floor afterwards vacuuming up chips
i wouldn't go with that somebody else
said that the reason that they have it
is because it's easy to
clean up puke stains i don't know what
it is
but please please bring me more theories
to that because i find it fascinating
there has to i
out of everything that i i that was just
i just read there
i believe it's a confusing pattern
and it adds to the confusion of trying
to get the [ __ ] out of there and then
you just next thing you know you're
playing a game
that one seems to make the most sense to
me all right
um here's the next one here what the
[ __ ] am i here
all right dear bilbo [ __ ] i have
recently discovered my lifelong friend
is in fact an [ __ ] first let me give
you some backstory
i've been friends with this kid since
car seats and baby teeth so last year
when i'm looking to move into a new
place i naturally turn to him
oh that's that's not a good thing to do
living you know one of the quickest ways
to end a lifelong friendship is to go
and live with somebody
just think of all the people who've
fallen in love you're my soul mate they
get married and within five years
you know one of them goes mysteriously
missing
you know by the way that's a bad thing
to do if you're gonna kill your wife or
your husband you should really go
practice on some homeless people and
prostitutes first
you know get you get your murdering game
up to par
you know to really try and get away with
the murder with your first murder
when you you have everything to gain
with that person being gone it's no
wonder everybody gets caught
you know you gotta you gotta suck it up
you gotta push your ego down and go to
the miners first
get some at-bats down there with the
[ __ ]
the [ __ ] newark bears take a couple
of pokes you know
get out there shake the rust off
um sorry anyways
so because last year i decided to move
into a new place
i naturally uh so when i'm looking to do
that i naturally turn to him he was
living on his own with his cousin
was happy to move in with me now since i
have known him so long
i know his tendency to be a slob i
discuss with this with him before we
moved in
and let him know i could only tolerate
so much uncleanliness
he responded back in kind and agreed now
flash forward to after i move in
i wake up in the middle of the night to
snoring that can wake the dead
i do what any normal person would do and
go out and ask him to do something since
it was keeping me up
the kicker is he wasn't even in his room
he's laying on the
floor in the living room so i wake him
up and ask him if he could either a
stop snoring or b go to his room this
elicits no response
from the beast he attempts confrontation
and finally relinquishes to his room
yeah this guy's uh he sleeps pretty hard
um he goes this has happened on and off
now for the past year usually he just
gives me the finger now
just gives me the finger now when i wake
him up for snoring
clearly i get the impression that he
only cares about himself
and gives two shits about anybody else
there's other things like him not
cleaning up after himself
not caring for his pet and some smoking
habits that are less than appealing
i'm willing to compromise though but he
just makes no effort he refuses to
address
any of it he always says he thinks of me
as family but i don't imagine anybody
treating their family like this
actually that's exactly how you treat
family because you know they're not
going to leave you
um so he goes so now so now i'm moving
out and i haven't told him
this is the reason so what do i what so
bill what do i do
do i tell him he's an [ __ ] and tell
him to kick rocks or just forget about
it and let bygones be by guns
you just forget about it dude all right
because this guy was your best friend
until you live with them
just like just feel bad for his future
wife
and this is the deal one of these days
you know
he'll bring up you guys living together
and you'll just laugh about it and just
be like dude
i left because i swear to god i was
fantasizing about going out
into the living room and chopping your
[ __ ] head off
you know or just [ __ ]
stuffing a chloroform rag in your
goddamn mouth
you know you can just laugh about it but
to uh right now with how upset you are
at him
it's going to affect your friendship um
you know if you're done being friends
with the guy i would bring it up now
but if you're not then i would just uh
i would use that story to get laid
that's what i would do because it'll be
a funny story and as you're telling the
funny story the woman's going to be
listening being like oh my god this
guy's considerate
he picks up after himself i have this
unbelievable urge to suck his dick now
what is that why do i do that guys
that's how i would use it all right and
then whenever he brings it up just laugh
about it that's like uh i live with uh
bobby robert kelly one of my best
friends in the whole wide world we
almost killed each other when we lived
together
[Music]
and he was a [ __ ] slob and i was the
[ __ ] i mean i'm not even that neat
that's the thing i'm not even that neat
like i don't make the [ __ ] bed every
day you know i always have three four
days of clothes but
i get it to that point three four days
and then i pick up
i'm pretty good about doing the dishes
but he was just like i'd come back from
the road and there would be like
dishwater like six days old or something
and there'd be like noodles from like
the chinese food floating in there it
was like
uh we didn't have any rubber gloves and
i'd have to stick my hand
on reach for that plug oh it was [ __ ]
nasty we lived in such a [ __ ] hole
i got to talk to him about that someday
if he remembers we had this [ __ ]
kitchen
the countertop was this was plastic
i don't i don't know what it was like
this hard plastic and it was
yellow and it was dirty it was
it was so [ __ ] gross like you
couldn't even cook in there
it had this [ __ ] stove i swear to god
that if you just you could
rock it back and forth two three times
it would literally come down like an old
shack
it was such a piece of [ __ ] and then the
guy who
his name was on the lease used to keep
his smelly hockey stuff
out there in the kitchen it was the most
disgusting [ __ ] thing
and then there was three guys living
there and like [ __ ]
we had like a bathroom basket out in the
kitchen
not a big like kitchen size a bathroom
one so it was always always overflowing
with whatever the [ __ ] you ate it was
[ __ ] it was nasty
ugh that really just took me back to a
bad period in my life
although it's funny now it's funny
yesterday i was over with bobby and his
lovely wife
eating some dinner she cooked a [ __ ]
tremendous meal and we started laughing
about the old days living together right
and i'm still friends with them
you know and you know what i did i
addressed what a slob he was while we
were
living together and we went like six
months without even speaking to each
other
after we moved out and you know what you
don't want to go through that type of
[ __ ]
but we were both young and immature
maybe that's where you're at maybe you
got to go through it
i don't [ __ ] know anyway success
story hey there billy redface
i'll keep this short but you gave me
spot-on advice
a few months ago about my cheating
ex-wife so i sincerely thank you well
you're welcome sir and if anybody's
listening to this
know that i'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] so every
once in a while like you know you play
darts long enough you're going to hit a
bullseye
all right but you guys listen to me and
my advice at your own [ __ ] risk
all right so anyways he goes i couldn't
be happier
my real question is how long were you
single before you met nia
and would you care to share any of your
bad dating stories
um thanks and [ __ ] said the kid in the
[ __ ] penguins bruins in six
all right bruins fans um how long was i
single i was single for quite a while
um i don't remember so [ __ ] long ago
i don't know a couple of years
a couple of years but i was now i was
never good at being single doing that
whole [ __ ]
playboy thing you know talking girls
into bed and all that type
i always felt like [ __ ] afterwards
unless the girl was like [ __ ] smoking
hot and then you had i can't believe she
slept with me man
you know kind of vibe i never uh
i don't know you know this by the time i
figured out how to talk a woman in bed
by then
i was like in my early 30s and there was
always something that you know if you
[ __ ] talk to somebody like you know
22 23 and they're just fresh out of
college i i literally it was like the
[ __ ] verges
of watching those rednecks hunting bear
with dogs
you know i just didn't feel the uh the
sense of accomplishment after a while
you know i'm a big softy what can i tell
you
anyways the man great system everybody
father's day it's right around the
corner everybody
all right and who's dad doesn't like to
grill
you know everybody's dad likes to go out
there even the people who don't like to
grill
there's just something about being a guy
cooking some
raw meat over an open flame i don't know
what it is
you do you actually in your in your head
you feel like you hunted that thing down
like you shot that cow you know
that saber-tooth cow you just you i
don't know what it does it's in your dna
so this father's day think the man great
what is the man great you ask well i'm
gonna tell you
put your eyebrows down because here
comes the information they are 100
made in america cast iron grilling
grates that are revolutionizing the way
people grill
heavy-duty grilling grates deliver
exactly what you need to achieve that
perfect steakhouse flavor that's making
me hungry
right now chicken steak or veggies will
never have tasted so good
no more flare-ups no more dry meat
guaranteed
named one of the 2012's best grilling
accessories by men's health magazine
man greats are the perfect gift for dad
this father's day go to man great dot
com and enter the coupon code bur
b-u-r-r for their 1999 father's day
special
or click the man great banner on the uh
on the show website
20 bucks you're gonna hook up your dad
for the whole
summer and basically if you don't
understand what they are you know when
you buy a grill
they come with those anorexic you know
like those aluminum
grill racks you know you're trying to
mark up your steak it doesn't look good
but then when you go to a steakhouse
they got those nice thick ones you know
what i mean
that's what those are it's basically
it's like a hot rod
you're upgrading the quality and it's
100 percent made in america 100 percent
cast iron 100 percent steakhouse quality
grilling in your backyard all right so
remember each monday morning podcast
order also comes with a heavy duty
grilling brush
for 20 bucks people again that's the
mandrake grill enhancement system order
today
man great dot com mandatory man great
dot com and enter the coupon code burr
burr at checkout all right all right
last advertising of the week
week week legal zoom everybody
america was built by innovators and
dreamers
people like edison henry ford and then
they write feel free to add your own
example
of an innovator dreamer
because last week i i laughed when i
read steve jobs
uh edison henry ford and joe derosa
joe's a dreamer he likes dreaming
because dreaming can make him mine um
but it's the inventors and enterprise
entrepreneurs all around us people like
you
that made america such a great country
that's right
this month legalzoom celebrates
innovators by helping what they're
really saying there was at some point
edison and henry ford were just like you
going to a football game with that
plastic hat with the beer cups and the
straw to your mouth
you know and then one day they were like
i got to get my s together
the next thing you know you got lights
in a car all right so what are you doing
what great idea are you sitting on that
you need to protect it
you don't want some corporation to steal
it from you go to legalzoom.com
this month legalzoom celebrates
innovators by helping them launch
their dreams apply for a patent to
secure your in your invention how
awesome is that
applying for a patent register your
trademark to protect your products
services incorporate or form an llc
and launch your business dream just call
or visit legalzoom.com
and they'll take care of you from start
to finish they've already helped a
million businesses get started
the right way okay so if you got that
great idea
okay the first step towards your dream
is going to legalzoom.com and making
sure
that you're incorporated so nobody can
sue you
and and the next one is you got to get a
patent so nobody can steal your idea
all right then you're off to the races
and i hope all you guys make a zillion
dollars and it all starts with
legalzoom.com
all right let's get back to the
questions here um i really do want that
for all you guys you know if you're
happy in a cubicle i know i break your
balls about that but if you're happy you
don't give a [ __ ] then you know
happiness i'd like i'd like to like for
you to achieve happiness
um so anyways off to join the army
all right this is a good memorial day
email hey bill thanks for all the fun
well you're welcome he said i've come to
a point
uh in life where decisions have to be
made
for the past seven years i've been
working within an industry that has
thrown me so many curveballs and [ __ ]
yous that it just doesn't seem normal
the brief roundup of what i've been
through
[ __ ] can three once three three weeks be
after buying a house oh my god
you know i've never had to deal with
stress that level i can't imagine that
one
number two business closed two weeks
before my wedding
oh my god so not only you're not making
money you now have to be even more
involved in the wedding planning because
you don't have the i gotta go to work
excuse all right number three numerous
dead-end jobs
and whatnot leading up to today although
i have had the pleasure of listening to
the wise words of burr
i don't know about that dude you're
listening to a [ __ ] that you can relate
to
you said uh i have decided enough is
enough i'm off to join the army
going to do a trade throwing away eight
years within the tech industry to become
a chef
um so be a chef in the army
there you go you just hang back and peel
potatoes
that's what i know you're not even that
you [ __ ] make that shitty army food
taste
unbelievable you know then you gotta
then you know then you get fans within
the army
then you come out don't blow all your
money on hookers and all of that
[ __ ]
save all your [ __ ] money
be a chef in the goddamn army and then
when you get out
you know start your own restaurant i'd
experiment with food
and find out what the average american
likes
you know you have an in total like
demographic right there running the
gamut you got people from all 50 states
all right and some of them know how to
cook maybe the southern guy can teach
you how to make some of that [ __ ]
barbecue
you know somebody out in buffalo can
show you how to make some wings that are
juicy on the inside
crunchy on the outside this is a
tremendous opportunity you can go see
the [ __ ] world
and uh i know there's other people in
the army see the [ __ ] world over the
middle of this [ __ ] [ __ ]
i know i'm sorry i'm trying to put a
positive spin on this
yeah it is it is what you what it's what
you what you put into it here so he goes
there's a lot of hard work ahead yeah
that guy yelling in your ear
what kind of chef do you know can go
through an obstacle course i hope you're
gonna do some push-ups buddy
and he goes it'll be well worth it in
the end if all goes to plan i'll be away
from home
and the wife for eight months nobody
said i'd get a holiday
too uh lol anyways just wanted to say
thanks and i'll be sure to listen always
even when i'm living on some base far
away from my friends and family all
right dude
well good luck for you man do you feel
like that's the right way to go
i hope you come back to being a chef
though man you know if
that's actually in your heart um
you know it's funny that story just
reminded me of something and i was
laying down and then i just sat up and
now i can't even [ __ ] remember
the [ __ ] i can gotta go back and reread
some of this [ __ ] chef
the hard work will be worth it
ah [ __ ] what happened to my brain
huh what happened to it everybody all
right
we're almost oh i know what it was
getting into shape
i got to show you this youtube video and
by the way i love youtube more than
anything on the [ __ ] planet it's one
of the things that i always go to
but this whole thing where they they're
not letting you say i don't want to use
my real name
you know i don't want to use my real
name i don't
not because i write [ __ ] [ __ ] just
because i don't want people knowing who
the [ __ ] i am
you know i don't even really leave that
many comments on youtube
but you know what it is i just don't
like how they're not giving me the
option to say
no so you keep hitting the refresh
button and you know it's getting to the
point
you know well you know what i would do
if i had any sort of computer savvy i
would just start a total ripoff of
youtube where you could remain anonymous
and you just have the exact same [ __ ]
videos
and anyways i i don't know how i i'll
try to find this youtube video we're
going to have it up there
this guy has this [ __ ]
plank position five minute [ __ ]
workout that i'm gonna start doing
you know the plank position where you
basically it's like you're in the pus-up
push-up position but you're
you're you're on your forearms
so he he does each one of these
positions for 15 seconds all right
this is basically the workout as far as
i can remember all right
so you're doing the original plank
position you're on your forearms 15
seconds all right
next 15 seconds you just have your left
arm
pointed straight ahead like you're doing
siege heil kyle hitler right
you do that and then after 15 seconds
you put that down now the right hand
heil hitler right this is by no means
pro nazi i'm just trying to give you a
visual here
or you could just watch the [ __ ]
video all right then the next 15 seconds
your left leg straight out
put that down then your right leg
straight out right and then
then you go uh left leg
right hand right arm that's like a
balance of thing and then the opposite
of that
then you go to your so you go to it's
[ __ ] insane like the longest i've
ever been able to plank position when i
was in really good shape was like two
minutes
so i'm on this [ __ ] i'm on this [ __ ] all
right so do it with me
i'm gonna uh put a link up to the
podcast page the youtube video and
hopefully you don't have to go through
that rigmarole of
having to leave your real name if you do
just hit the refresh button but i found
lately if you hit the refresh button too
much
it just keeps going back to it then you
just have to shut it off
and then just click on youtube again
it's a pain in the ass i don't know why
they're doing it if anybody knows why
um i mean one of it i find it kind
of would be great if people who write
all that racist [ __ ] actually had to
leave their real names maybe they
wouldn't
um but what does that really solve
they're still going to be racists you
know
they just know not to say it out loud so
they won't lose their jobs right
isn't that right i don't [ __ ] know
anyways
um that's the podcast for this week
everybody
um i still had a couple of good ones to
read here can you remind you yeah what
what what else you got to do it's
memorial day right let's read a couple
more
horses uh hey bill thanks for your
relationship
uh think of your relationship with your
dog
this is what you can you can have with a
horse but it's more oh yeah because i
said if i ever had a horse
i'd love to have a horse that i never
rode i hate that whole breaking the
horse
he goes dogs are kind of like
happy-go-lucky buddies they have a
lightness
horse are like noble dogs they are a
little smarter
and can be even more emotional than a
dog so they uh
so they can be even more loyal than a
dog they they have to be one over
oh you left out the b they have to be
won over with respect
and once you do this they consider it a
pleasure to have you ride them
it's a two-way thing that's hard to
describe watch the movie black beauty
the one with alan cummings as the voice
and go [ __ ] yourself um
all right i i don't know that they
would you ever find it a pleasure to
have 150
to 200 pounds on your back
imagine if you had a backpack that
weighed let's just say 180 pounds
and not only was it on your back it was
[ __ ]
slapping your ass telling you to go
faster
and which way to go
would you enjoy that i don't know more
horse stuff i want to know
i want to know because i love horses but
i just can't i could never break one
that would kill me that really would
that would hurt my [ __ ] hat uh
underrated
uncle billiam this could be the
underrated of the century
keeping your dick in check flipping the
script on the ladies
and refusing your woman's sex i just
told my girl no sex till she goes and
applies for 10 jobs today
and the look on her face was priceless
like she just had no clue
what just happened looked like a little
kid that had just been
just had its teddy bear stolen love the
podcast and go [ __ ] yourself your
redheaded bastard uh yeah that's a great
one
that's a great one i mean you're [ __ ]
with that that's you know what you
having your dick in check
is like your woman um [ __ ] bench
pressing more than you
that's basically it i mean the core
thing a guy has over a woman
is that he's physically stronger okay
core thing a woman has is she is that
we're run by our dicks well i mean
they're all so smart i think they're
just they're
i do think women are smarter in a lot of
areas
just because they have to be it's a
nature thing you know
we're stronger so we don't we i think we
just didn't use our brains as much
back when you could [ __ ] drag a woman
around by her hair
and beat her with a branch i said shut
the [ __ ] up
you know didn't have to grow as a human
being they had to sit there and be like
how do i get that big dumb oaf
to do exactly what i want him to do i
can't grab him by the [ __ ] throat
how can i make him do it and actually
make him feel like
it's his decision you know
anyways whatever that's the podcast for
this week go [ __ ] yourselves
um i'm touring with the teen idol
sensation
we're going to be at the count basie
theater this wednesday
you know one o'clock jump count basie
[ __ ] theater
out in red bank new jersey and then
we're going down to some [ __ ] theater
in baltimore i don't have the names of
these
on friday and then saturday i don't know
i'm in some place in uh
no thursday i'm in baltimore friday i'm
in pennsylvania
and then saturday i winded up with two
shows
down there and what do you call it in
[ __ ] atlantic city
and uh tickets have been selling
unbelievable the best i've ever sold in
my career and i want to thank all you
guys it means the world to me that you
guys are coming out to my shows
and i get to continue living my dream
here all right so thank you for that
that's the podcast like i said go [ __ ]
yourselves
have a great memorial day and uh i'll
talk to you next week